ah ou je voyais
pas
combien tu PRS
ci derrière c'est vach en
plus
différence de contraste entre le jaune
et le blanc c'est magnifique je pens pas
Caravan comm
çaign comme ça jamais
d'abitantou pas
grosire c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon c'est
bon oh c'est inoui ça quand tu penches
un tout petit peu voilà
j'ai une merde encore
ça ouais en haut dans dans le planan oh
là là je la vois pas si si je la
vois
nettoyer laisse finir
ouis
fin dans le bleu il
ouais voilà mais faut nettoyer j'arrive
même pas à la voir je la vois en ha par
que c'est beau dis donc c'est
génial nettoi
ouais
[Musique]
c'est génial génialce que c'est
impressionnant ave ton pied c'est une
bonne idée ça différence tout de
suite regarde il Mar les VO en
plus pas trop pr
t'inquiète qu' vient tous n
voirê alors pas
et donc tu veux le bu produit hein tu
Vasin attendsin alle coup temps avant
d'ouvrir il pas l'air de bonne humeur
euh difficile à dire quand même voilà
c'est bon c'est bon on y va parce que
j'ai pas envie vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y
vas-y alle on y va
çais qu'arrête la caravane
ah c'est bon
bon on
recommence qu'est-ce que c'est beau
attaché je suis attaché
tout de suite ils ont des boulet hein
vous VZ voir ce qui se passait c'est des
mecs qui sont hélicoptère qui se POS il
vienent voir c'est PL
sympathtique à droite hein
tourne ah ouais
ok allez vas-y moteur
tour pas
peurinquièinquè
a
ça
tranquille TR c'est
génial plus régulier tu crois
paspression que
c'estainant oh
merde me son tout à l'URE c'est pour
ça-ce que tu as
[Musique]
dit pour
l'stant comm pour moi s'il vous
plaît
non va recommencer pr on
démarmar
recommence tout le monde ser en
mouvement
comme ça
ontin
quand face tu as d arrêter les
chameaux je
pense les premiers s'arrê donc ça BL
tout le
reste
je la
encore he on
he magnifque le me avecon sur le dos
c'est
super que c'est beau
ça bravo Fran de
vu vu
çait et je te dis pas aligner group quoi
des gros un gros troupeau quoi si tu
veux regarde avec les couleurs regarde
la différence de sable ça qui est
sublime différence
de avec lesbes à chameau et tout c'est
magnifique W c'esté c'est
sublime vas-y tu peux descendre en
restant la même tu vois que je puisse
resserrer dedans
c'est du boutve les sa différents c'est
sublime voilà tu vois c'est là où tu es
comme c'est beau c'est super super super
voilà c'est
çatite c'est bien ça
g pas beaucoup plus pour
voilarder un peu
[Musique]
de plus beau comme ça
ou oh les couleurs de sable dans l'ER à
Ch petit mec au milieu là qui marche
avec dans la boucle là c'est
magnifique faire quoi attends je va
taper serr suivre tranquillement sur le
côté tu attends attends reste là a plein
taper déjà
là reste là
ok
coupe
imagin c'est avec des belles
[Musique]
ombres
ge le moi fixe un pe unu c'est pas on
est là on est là donc on le fait là pu
on faire de
tranquille
des plans
moyens
pas du tout comment en
en des trucs tu vois des trucs en c'est
vraiment des Plock là on l'impression
heinmi bien ça
un peu de do pas très beauve on vibre un
peu je pense
ouais c'est
M voilà ça c'est des PL jolis voilà
voilà c'est joli ça mais à droite en
ha met à gauche de l'image met à gauche
c'est c'est
ça j'adore ça me qui marche avec voilà
voilà voilà voilà voilà ça ça c'est le
plan
coupe voil c'est génial voil
GAE et en ha ça REP à gauche encore
c'est magnifique regarde un peu ce
plan super
super
ce que j'aime c'est la couleur des
différences de sable ça alors là
[Musique]
ça déc est
sublime
mieux
descendè la dun et faire apparaître dans
cette valeur
là
vu le en haut le plan que tu es en haut
là quand tu es en haut tuas les tu as
l'arrondi avec les
deux c'est joli
[Musique]
ça allez
le paysage il incroyable au
télé
bon att je ma sortie vasy fr
ami doucement douc
continu deond voilà
voilà
continue
tuarrière l'arrière et je t'amènerai
l'alignement devant
d'accordcord tu mets un peu en bas de
l'image et tu montes un peu de tout le
ciel quand assez large inoui mais bien
en bas d'image plus beau comme ça voilà
quand même voilà tu
vois ça c'est une ligne
indéfinie
plus àite
pour à
gauche pas
trop quiène que Sin l'OM voil c'est
déb
pas pr
rayer on peut relaisser défiler si tu
veux ouais attends
attendseeeee tu avances tu vois que je
termine sur la fin voilà c'est ça voilà
pas les effer non
plus
bonjour cou
pour
VO
ok vas-y pour
bien à
[Musique]
drite
plus intéressant contre jour je
trouve plus dé
[Musique]
plusême plus stable
non ok vas-y
eff comme tu
veux couleur blanche jaune mais ça c'est
un coup de chance alors là pter sur leil
le blanc c'est superbe superbe
superbe
[Musique]
couleur
mettoi regarde sur le sable làbas
blancun tu les vois au bout de l'image
là faut vraent que tues dedans un peu ou
en moyen
ouais
bon regarde derrière avec le cor
derrière c'est
magnifique
[Musique]
ouil c'est un peu je peux plus rien
faire Fran
ou je te les mets
après poigner de ta
porte carrément puni désolé tu as vu
comment on est dans le lit du c'est plus
cool ça c'est super beau
ça
j'arrive comment tu veux
bien prends tout le décor tu vois doncir
du blanc partout ça va être sublime ça
tu vois y aller y
aller doucement doucement doucement
doucement doucement doucement doucement
pr le temps de regarder temp de
regarderir très par
là un gauche
droite maintenant
gauche et
droite
merci sont lesquel les
derniers
de la
gueule alle
[Musique]
mur un peu plus en bas de
l'image
magnifique
ça change de couleur entre le jaune et
le tu vois le jaune et
l'ORE quand tu vas aller plus loin tu
vas voir aller sur du blanc encore avec
des ombres très belles
doucement doucement doucement
fr je laisse te faire
lu
oh c'est
interminable il sur sur du blanc regarde
les ombres les ombres en
plus les vertic regarde
att c'est très long
ça
c'est dernier dernier
dernier c'est
interminable comme
ça
coup
tenant
justeix allez vas-y
moteur
[Musique]
on aura vu ça le soir dis donc
ouais ah ouais le soir mais à
[Musique]
tombé mieux en filme qu'en photo parce
qu'en photo il y a tellement de de trucs
un peu partout que tu les perds un peu
estce qu'en fum tu vois qu' a ça qui
bouge quoi tu
vois c'est pas un très joli très joli je
trouve là pas toi toi il y en a pas
assez
ou
allez attends 2
secondes c'est pas
mal deess ouais non non non non c'est
juste une selle he là con
là ahon c'est une rafale to ça
derrière et
tout tu sais
ça
réc un sur la droite on y va c'est la
grosse ce c'est les solid c'est lui qui
ouvre la
marche tuir la poussière donc faut que
[Musique]
j'avance reste sur luiaccord
ouais pas encore mais c'est pour ça faut
que je dégage là
ok ah merde tu aurais d rester sur lui
je t'amener les autres après bon c'est
pas grave on avait de la poussière dans
l'image encore un peu on va mettre sur
eux aussi
leses à chameau c'est beau
ça
je suis vraiment je
sais sinon c'est un peu
rapide 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
30 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 on va
4 moi ce que je ferais
bien fa
arrê çao tout monde
est plein soleil là j'ai peur que ce
soit moins visible
que je vois pas où tu
es il avance plus
merde non on leur fait peur on leur fait
peur à
gauche
ok
oup c'est allez vas-y
tout
magnifique ça ça c'est très très bon que
j'aime
ça des graphismes sal c'est
magnifique
allez
arrête-toi
partout c'est vachement bien ça pass
colline
[Musique]
truc
ok
c
il y a de ch qui
[Musique]
sont
son
av décharge fa recharger un
autre il sont le
décharger
grand
ouverte
peuttre sou un peu
derrière
c'est
[Musique]
devant pas passer devant en avançant
doucement sur eux en voyant la caravane
sur le
côté attends reste comme ça reste comme
ça pu il va avancer va continuer comme
ça tu vas continuer à les voir il vont
passer dans le soleil vas-y Fran qui tu
continues comme ça tu restes devant
reste dessus reste dessus je reste
dessus ouais moi
j'our les Chau qui va faire un truce
ça on Fa tu V rester dedans
voilà qu'il fasse de la poussière tu
restesi dedans voil vasy voilà comme ça
voilà se lèveè seè il faut relever le
chon
[Musique]
vasy après ça pourra changer de cassette
CIS qu'on a fini là non tu ve faire un
are
plan je ce que tu veux
faire alle reste
[Musique]
fixe
on souff un
peu souff un peu devant objectif
photo maximum
c'est marrant ça c'est vraas
raison ça tient ça tient en
qualité ça doit
ouais un peu d'abération optique mais
bon
la
déser
REM doucement comme ça tu peux
Remon
ça va couper
là
c fa arrêter
allez
bon